they're having none of it
marie-josée the Azevedo tries to
persuade voters to say no to the pro
Nacional but these two won't be
convinced the activist says it's nothing
new systemic the discussions are pretty
tough it's not open-minded at all no
real exchange we succeed with some
though and others are even happy to see
that not everybody in pleasures is for
the fullness you're not :
vicious has become a showcase for the
right-wing nationalist party one of the
first things the new front us you know
mayor did three years ago was to take
down the EU flag now the Town Hall just
boasts the French trickle or his critics
accused the for national of trying to
intimidate the opposition it all said
don't set G lips because it's not a
democratic party you're sanctioned as
soon as you oppose anything for example
political associations are cut from
funding or get evicted from their
offices the only choice they have then
is to retire the pronoun soon as local
office is right next to the town hall
and today it's busy a team is planning
the campaign strategy for the next day's
Pat speak to ATO a former conservative
is now a big fan of the party's Law &
Order approach the Haines's general
marine really wants to tighten the
screws so all those who get 20 years in
prison really served 20 years and don't
get released earlier and all foreigners
who commit crimes and murders they need
to go home get punished there why should
we support all those who commit crimes
in France
on the campaign trail this resonates
well with large parts of the local
electorate the Jews the mayor also
started reducing the mountain of public
debt and beefed up the police presence
the accusations about strangling the
political opposition and civil liberties
are brushed aside by his supporters SSS
Yogi's there will always be associations
that are against upon us you know but it
can't be right that associations get
funded by the mayor's office yet are
involved in activities against our party
that's why some years ago some
associations were shut down because they
use public money to engage in anti
honest you know politics
hiya aye but what is really happening in
this showcase for the nationalist party
most remember the city for its ancient
Roman splendor but below the surface
things seem to be changing in critius
today populace Joseph Marie Josie
Acevedo and fellow activist jaha said
boon bring the DWT into a social center
that was shut down by the mayor suddenly
the police show up and want to know what
we are doing here for the two activists
that would not have happened under
previous administrations
what is the absolutely symptomatic o for
the extreme right it's their obsession
to know everything and to infiltrate
people's lives in order to exploit them
as much as they can
phenomenal talent la vie de Jean Paul is
export your maximum so why is it that so
many people are happy with what the four
national is doing in kazoos there's only
safe pesky spies okay people just don't
know what is really happening in the
city they don't care especially about
social things it would be enough that
they just read the newspapers to know
what's happening
they probably just read FM top again
yellow Facebook before my PB caps about
exact mo skis bezel-set villa claims the
party and many of its voters deny in any
case this riff delicious gives a taste
of what life in france would be like
under a president lepen